there's Rodney hood garden curry hood  had the lead game 7 Sunday with  hyper-extended knee as current roles at  3.0 giving the rock up and relocating  unselfish play puts himself in position  and knock down the same mentality with  Steph Curry the only shoot on the floor  curry gets a good look nails another  three but there's not shooting on the  floor get up with the screen so curry  can't you pull up curry launches again  Donnell picks it up throws it ahead to  curry curry for three  when green asked him a million questions  mega dolla says he's one of the smartest  young players he's ever seen in his  years in the league curry for three  again they drop 20 back on the  pick-and-roll curry walks into the three  and knocks it up curry for three  this eighth three-pointer of the game  you kidding me this is going to be a  great night for me  that Steph Curry and there were tonight  I'm saying that's why you're getting  paint curry gets sprayed curry for three  [Applause]